martine michel ses épaules le sont avec
nous bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir alors
le recul certains disaient aujourd'hui
bas c'était écrit dans le ciel toujours
utile qui recule aujourd'hui sur cette
taxe pour les non vaccinés
la manifestation a pesé dans la balance
il le reconnaît monsieur legault est dit
là c'est le moment maintenant d'oublier
ce qu'on a dit est de refaire une
cohésion sociale je veux entendre
monsieur legault et les oppositions
convient en parler dans la balance
aujourd'hui je pense est important de
protéger la paix sociale de protéger la
cohésion sociale de rassembler les
québécois dont je pense que
la contribution santé aurait pu
aider à être un incitatif pour certaines
personnes on voit une grogne grandir
j'ai vu évidemment la réaction des
partis d'opposition donc je pense que
j'ai aussi une responsabilité au delà de
protéger la sécurité des québécois en
incitant les québécois soient vaccinés
j'ai aussi une responsabilité que tout
ce monde-là réapprennent à vivre
ensemble
le directeur de la santé publique
démissionne le premier ministre nous
arrive avec une idée une idée qui est
irréfléchie pour lequel il a pas
consultés mais s'il a consulté ses pets
une maison de sondages cette taxe broche
à foin l'a jamais été rien d'autre
qu'une stratégie politique ça aurait
ajouté aucun lit dans nos hôpitaux ça
aurait ramené aucune infirmière dans
notre système public le premier ministre
aime beaucoup dire que les québécois
sont tannés oui les québécois sont
tannés sont tannés des incohérences sont
tannés de l'improvisation des ballons
d'essai on a mis en place le passeport
vaccinale qu'on a élargi on avait lancé
l'idée d'une contribution santé mais on
veut rassembler les québécois
voilà vous avez tout entendu ce qui est
important aujourd'hui dans les extraits
martin monsieur la godzilla s'est plu à
et suscité le plus de monde possible oui
ça reste une volonté de vacciner plus
seulement mais la cohésion sociale ça
devient un élément qu'il faut prendre en
compte ça prend des appuis aussi pour
mener ce type de projet de loi là et
c'est ce qui était prévu pour cette
semaine je veux dire deux choses là
dessus de choses qui sont liées d'abord
le vent a tourné les gars trois semaines
monsieur legault avait quand même
l'appui de son caucus pour aller de
l'avant avec de telles mesures et le
caucus présessionnel que eu lieu jeudi
vendredi en virtuel a montré qu' il
avait changé de cap et les caucus sans
cesser les yeux et les oreilles du
premier ministre sur le terrain et j'ai
eu 20 de ces discussions là en fin de
semaine puis j'ai poussé un peu les
recherches pour me rends compte que
beaucoup de députés on n'était plus
d'accord avec ces mesures là même il ya
quelqu'un qui me dit députés que me dit
le premier ministre avait même l'air
surpris du changement cadre de son
caucus alors il se retrouve dans une
situation où il ya plus son caucus
derrière lui il n'ya pas les partis
d'opposition il ya certains éléments de
la santé publique ou si publiquement on
dit rush pas certaine monsieur le
ministre dubé en point de presse
aujourd'hui avait pas tellement l'air
non c'est
alors la situation s'est tu t'envoles en
année électorale dans une situation tu
vas affronter un vent de face ce que tu
veux en année électorale su distribuer
des bonbons pas mettre des mesures
coercitives donc michel suau j'ai ça ne
vous a pas étonné outre mesure non plus
non parce qu'il y avait des problèmes
aussi littéralement technique là les dix
personnes et 10 pour sa déjà pour
vacciner ses poteaux c'est ce surtout
pas des gens qui sont des amis de ceux
qui sont devant lé parlement à ottawa
aujourd'hui y avait toutes sortes de
monde maintenant il y avait des sans
abri j'avais déjà gagné problèmes de
santé mentale des gens qui parlent pas
français anglais alors un moment donné
ça a été très compliqué de faire ça en
plus est-ce qu'on veut avoir scène de
santé qui est là pour punir plus tôt
pour choyer c'est quand même une
question qu'il faut se poser la
situation l'a finalement bien
franchement est ce qu on veut que le
ministère du revenu peuvent jouer dans
nos dossiers de santé il ya des pas des
fois qu'ils sont mieux de rester fermés
l'argumentaire comptes commencent à
s'allonger par wii puis surtout qu'on a
réalisé que c'était pas applicable ou à
tout le moins que c'est un pic à mme
sala arrivé trop tard parce que il y
avait deux arguments en fonction de
seuils le premier c'était l'argument de
la cohésion sociale
ironiquement maintenant c'est devenu la
marque mais à l'époque on disait que
c'est justement au nom de la cohésion
sociale qui paraît serré la vis aux non
vaccinés pour calmer la grogne des gens
vaccinés à leur endroit
donc c'était le meilleur lui manque que
ça diminue pilotage non c'est ça va
inciter des gens à se faire vacciner
sauf que cette mesure la
nécessité un projet de loi donc on a
besoin de l'appui de l'opposition pour
que son étude se fasse assez rapidement
mais si vous avez un projet doivent
battait contre l'opposition vous
finissez seulement par le faire adopter
je ne sais pas en mai qu'en juin alors
que la science est la cinquième banque
sera derrière nous ben il sait quoi
l'utilité de sa finalement c'est quelque
chose qui arrive en retard qui est
réactif donc c'était pas forcément
applicable ou du moins applicable pour
être utile et la grogne dont parlait
monsieur legault elle est réelle on le
vit à ottawa et vous quand même beaucoup
de monde samedi on l'a vu à québec on
verra ça s'est pas produit on peut pas
être devin mais yann grave monsieur
legault veut pas mettre de l'huile sur
le feu rapidement à martin ilyasova son
caucus mais aussi il sent qu'il mettrait
de l'huile sur le feu mais stimulant
plus et il commença dès confiné
il met en place un calendrier ça
déconfite lentement mais les nouvelles
sont pas mauvaises on s'envoie vraiment
pour reprendre l'expression à la mode la
lumière au bout du tunnel il ya quand
même une opportunité pour l'huile qui
est devant lui alors est aussi bien
garder son calme et on va voir aussi ce
qui va se passer à québec le samedi on
vous parlait d' assouplissement ou et on
verra ce qui va se passer à québec en
effet on va on vous parlait d'
assouplissement mais martin
je vous fais entendre les partis
d'opposition
monsieur duhaime qui lui évidemment veut
plus d'assouplissement mais même les
oncles qui allez voir qu'ils disent là
serait le temps d'aller plus vite on ne
joue on a vu ce film là plusieurs
reprises à des fois c'est plus de mesure
des fois c'est moins on écoute la
réponse de monsieur le groupe emplir on
peut pas continuer à empêcher québec de
vivre pour sauver système de santé
éternellement système de santé de pour
sauver les québécois ce prix québécois
sont ceux posés par ces deux ans de leur
vie sur off pour sauver un système de
santé il arrivait avec un plan qui dit
voici un certain nombre
d'hospitalisations puis compte tenu du
retour des travailleurs qui était malade
ou si la met à tel moment on va poser de
tels gestes par tellement va poser de
tels gestes de manière à ce qu a
confiance l'adhésion reviennent dans le
coup
du parti conservateur du québec pas
surpris dans le code du parti québécois
je surpris de dit qu'on a
pas le droit
de mettre des incitatifs pour que les
gens se fassent vacciner pour éviter
d'engorger nos hôpitaux ça me surprend
c'est pas le parti québécois que je
connais puis quand j'entends le parti
québécois puis même québec soldati
tantôt que selon eu trop de restrictions
mais je trouve ça irresponsable
bon je sais débat là aussi page commence
avec vous tour de table sur est ce qu'on
devrait accélérer pas accélérer l'ont
annoncé pour le 14 février lidge aime
les sports pour les adultes entre autres
qu'en pensez vous le seul débat
je note que les choses évoluent vite
dans l'opinion publique et aussi dans
les positions des oppositions regardez
en décembre en novembre et en décembre
on reproche au gouvernement d'avoir trop
rapidement annoncer des relâchements
pour noël et d'avoir été trop lents pour
serrer les mesures avec l'arrivée de la
fin de la cinquième vague et là
maintenant c'est le contraire on dit
avant vous étiez trop laxistes
maintenant vous êtes trop restrictif et
il faut relâcher et l'autre chose qui
demandait c'est d'ajouter de la
prévisibilité s'est justifié en partie
mais semble-t-il mais quand même des
limites à la prévisibilité qu'on peut
avoir on n'a qu'à regarder l'effet du
retour en classe l'on commence à être
capable d'en mesurer les conséquences
mais quand même faut être vigilant par
rapport à ça et aussi par rapport aux
autres mesures le donc on relâche on
observe les faits et on se tombe
relation de plus on peut pas avoir un
calendrier très précis mais donner un
petit avant goût de prévisibilité le je
pense que oui l'a su il peut y avoir
consensus michel c que pensez vous de
cette valse sert dessert dessert sert
plus dans des serres plus
dans un monde idéal au frais pour ça
mais
le rire au micro-ondes au japon
mon idéal non plus bien plus les
restrictions ont pas le même effet sur
tout le monde y en a pour qui c'est ben
important que les jim son règne qui sont
ils pour qui c'est bien important que
les restaurants sont ouverts ce mois la
maman prend même gang mais à un moment
donné on fait qu'on peut pas faire
consensus et vexant on voit par exemple
dans les arts de la scène il ya des gens
qui disent mais ouvrir 50 % de ma salle
parce que vous pas en fait je vous vivez
pas qu'ils ont
alors
seul c'est vraiment difficile de
contenter tout le monde tout le monde
est content quand toutes les
restrictions vont être parti bon c'est
tout ce que c'est pas pour tout de suite
puis on sait tous que il peut y avoir
une autre bague et il va falloir
continuer notre foi
restauration bien que je laissais
pâtissent pas tout le monde que vécut
les cinq vagues de la même façon là
c'est sûr que les restaurateurs le sont
rendus à leur quatrième fermeture 4e et
ouverture c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont
vécu et bien très un article très
intéressant dans la presse en fin de
semaine sur les techniciens de la cin la
vague de suicides chez ces gens là on
prenait une pommade conscience-là de ce
que certaines personnes avaient vécu au
cours de ces différentes vagues et c'est
souvent les mêmes personnes qui sont
touchées vague après vague alors quand
là là là qu'on commence à descendre
c'est sûr que là la pression commence à
augmenter pour que l'on puisse dès
confiné davantage et des partis
d'opposition joue dans ce film là parce
que oui si dans leurs circonscriptions
où ils ont beaucoup de choses mais là on
construit en compte ces cinq vagues plus
tard c'est qu'on n'est peut-être pas
encore sortie de berges les landais au
micron et là on ne le sous verre rien de
micron qui arrive alors est ce que ea on
va voir une remontée mais sait on n'a
pas vraiment le choix de suivre ce jour
après jour puis s'est donné un peu d'air
jour après jour comme ça ça relâche un
peu oui on peut pas avoir des cartes
métriques puis avec tel chase acte
mattel chose ou
enfin aucun petit commentaire
de recherche en politiques publiques ont
montré que depuis le début de la
pandémie le québec est quand même une
des provinces les plus restrictifs sinon
la plus restrictive par rapport au
restaurant même si des restaurateurs ils
ont fait des efforts donc on voit qu'on
se démarquant sens le par la sévérité à
l'endroit de nos restaurants oui on est
la province la nation la plus
restrictive pour les restaurants mais je
compare même pas que les états unis la
question a été posée monsieur legault le
superbe or less que le 13 on pourrait
pas soupire le trait tout le 14 parce
que on voit des stades pleins bon ok je
veux partir de la coved puis je rentre
encore comme dans le film un dépôt me
battre le pavé trois
cerveaux veut rester et wayne o'toole
qu'est ce qui se passe
là on est tenté de dire celles les plus
à droite
les conservateurs sociaux qui se
révoltent mais c'est plus complexe la
révolte et peut-être même plus profonde
que ça à michel si je commence avec vous
il ya même des gens pop art by les
conservateurs sociaux cavell plus dur et
nantes où
j'ai eu tous les deux problèmes un
problème avec wind et conservateurs
sociaux à ce moment-ci mais il ya le
problème ne s'est appuyé sur eux pour
devenir chef du parti et après ça dira
non il faut concerner les au centre et
il s'est fait au cours d une la crise
des camionneurs encore exacerbée tous à
une espèce de réputation de girouette
non je rencontrerai pas les leaders du
mouvement des camionneurs oui j'allais
rencontrer oui mais je sors privé il
faudrait personne ne sache et puis et
c'est ça que les gens à un moment donné
dans le caucus conservateur
la plus légère surtout de l'est le plus
conservatrices mais quand même d'autres
disent bien s'appuient de bourse à ceux
partisane n'est pas très gentil avec ses
chefs cats perdent je me suis vue sur
ces quelque chose mais à l'air frais
surtout à peut-être contribué à son
malheur pas mal dans votre esprit michel
c'est réglé à demain il n'est plus chef
écouter même si il gagne avec méthode
55% à 60% je veux prouver votre chef du
parti sis à 40% de nos députés qui vous
tue le maître des couteaux dans le dos
de nos terres et en allant quand on
accroche la mer 80 cas je t'avais chaîne
infernale est avec les rochers ok c'est
ce qui le problème
et puis déjà
avant même la tenue du vote déjà si on
regarde son dos il n'y a pas beaucoup de
peau il ya plus de métal dedans il ya
déjà pas mal de couteau puis à chaque
journée quand il prend une position il
ya d'autres députés qui disent plus ou
moins le contraire
donc c'est une mission impossible si
monsieur o'toole essayent de plaire aux
gens plus à droite dans son caucus bah
écoutez y est déjà trop tard puis il
faut dire des choses qui vont l'empêcher
de gagner mais s'est dit le contraire
ils veulent et mécontente et puis en
fait son erreur aussi qui frustre
beaucoup de gens qui sont peut-être
moins social à droite réformiste qu'ils
ont l'impression mais aussi autour
change souvent d'opinion donc s'il est
inconstant et s'il déplaît à la base il
reste plus beaucoup d'arguments en sa
faveur mais des conservateurs la
question qui se pose c'est est ce que
quelqu'un quelque part pourrait rallier
ces deux trois courants différents chez
les bleus où on sera pas inévitablement
devant un parti divisé pour encore
plusieurs années au et monsieur trudeau
qui va être mort dorée plusieurs années
martin bah si c'est possible que ce soit
ça mais bon stephen harper a été capable
de tenir le parti ensemble visiblement
il le fait puis le naturel est revenu au
galop il ya réussi à garder ça en place
c'est sûr que monsieur autour le pain
narratif tout au long de son
de son 1
de son leadership où il a été capable de
garder les équipes ensemble meilleur
réutilise sa plateforme électorale en
pleine campagne électorale pour plaire
un plaire à l'autre même chose avec les
camionneurs alors c'est fait pas très
solides comme comme leader mais un peu à
l'époque michel et paul
lamarque libéral s'était effondré il y
avait le scandale des commandites qui
est arrivé il y avait effectivement
réussi l'union de la droite là qui a été
un élément déterminant
le contexte est différent les libéraux
sont pas à marcher comme l'étaient les
libéraux à l'époque est ce que parce que
la 6e' parle demain il faut qu'ils
pensent à le remplacer est ce que c'est
comme envoyer saint michel la suite des
jo ce soit possible parce que ce qui est
arrivé au cours des derniers mois depuis
depuis l'élection c'est que les socios
conservateurs eux ils sont devenus plus
forts dans le parti la goutte qui a fait
déborder le vase pour plusieurs et c'est
d'ailleurs sur la lettre du député qui
d'aubarne ce vote donnée de chips et
d'accepter le projet de loi à
l'unanimité sur l'interdiction des
thérapies de conversion seul à la droite
conservatrice l'époque lui alors ça
c'est l'élément nouveau
ces gens là sont maintenant devenus
carrément est ouvertement des ennemis de
sur une tôle ils sont plus nombreux que
ben alors
ç'a toujours été difficile de maintenir
les deux groupes
est-ce que c'est à cambrai c'est dans ce
contexte actuel ils sont séparés moment
donné survenu à 100 parce qu'il sera du
compte tu comprennes j'avais le pouvoir
s'il faisait pas mais
dans les coulisses nos
jeunes impression que le seul ciment
pour les factions opposées de ce parti
c'est l'attrait du pouvoir et donc il
faudrait un chef qui est suffisamment
populaire dans les sondages pour que les
gens entre eux voient le retour au
pouvoir et acceptent de mettre de côté
certains désaccords mais tant qu'ils
auront l'impression qu'ils sont dans la
position ils vont se dire je me dis ce
que je pense dans l'opposition que de
censure si ça m'avantage si ça me
rapproche pas plus d'une position
ministre il parallèle avec ces faits
dans prix très intéressant mais il faut
pas oublier qu'à l'époque c'était un
nouveau parti conservateur qui résultait
de la fusion de la droite réformer avec
le vieux parti conservateur progressiste
et donc les gens se disent on va donner
une chance à la fusion on a décidé de
mettre certains des accords de côté pour
revenir au pouvoir mais c'est plus ce
contexte là le ils ont essayé ça
fonctionne et ça ne fonctionne plus puis
il y en a qui ont bien le goût d'essayer
autre chose puis l'heure est plus à la
mutinerie qui a limité en ce moment et
on voit dans ces moments de crise mais
vous parliez de monnaies et michel
comment le jean charest on pourrait
aussi donner l'exemple comme un leader
vont jouer avec son caucus leveaux jouer
en équipe qui a besoin de son équipe
martin casca pour traverser une tempête
faut que je sois faut que tu donnes
envie à tout le monde de jouer avec toi
l'avait fait il n'y a pas eu lieu du
salat c'était très difficile de rallier
par exemple et les vieux du reform je me
rappelle de debra gré puis de monsieur
stoll aussi des députés qui qui qui
voulaient sortir du parti conservateur
parce qu'ils étaient plus à droite et et
ça a été long finalement sur harper a
réussi à les tenir ensemble avec peter
mackay mais aussitôt qu'ils étaient
partis mais monsieur mais qui a repris
son espace la très bien c'est tout un
conte à merci à vous trois bonnes
soirées à bientôt et merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
oh